welcome back to las vegas now it's the
season of giving so it's the perfect
time to support children in our
community through the las vegas rotary
club santa claus event here to tell us
more about the upcoming event is the las
vegas rotary club santa claus program
organizer michael gordon hi michael hi
jillian how are you good thank you so
much for being here we were talking a
little bit off-camera this is such a
cool event and you guys have been doing
it for a long time tell me all about it
yes so for this is our 26th annual santa
claus event so for the past 25 years
we've donated over 1.5 million in goods
and services to almost 6 000 kids in the
las vegas valley so we're so happy to
have it back the kids back this year
again because we know this is the time
of giving back yeah this is going to be
so special for them and what i love
about it is they get to actually come
and shop and pick out stuff how does it
all work yes so the kids show up we work
with 13 partner agencies agencies like
salvation army shade tree boys and girls
clubs they bring the kids to three
jcpenney's locations around the valley
and then the kids shop for coats shoes
socks shoes underwear
whatever they want because we want every
kid to leave with a new pair of clothes
that's so cool and we're seeing some
video from past years and the kids just
look so happy and they're having such a
special experience and in addition to
shopping you continue the day on and you
bring them over to unlv right yes our
club and i should say we use all the
clubs in the las vegas valley so we
believe in youth education and we want
them to experience the college
environment we know so many kids for
them it's first generation so they get
to interact with some of the unlv
athletes they render off some of that
energy that we get from the morning we
give them a lunch and then they hear an
inspirational talk about the importance
of education at unlv wow what a cool day
for them and this event is called santa
claus but santa claus makes an
appearance
yeah well
yes he shows up at the end we we cannot
do it without him and we cannot do it
without the support of the whole
community and if people want to get
involved where do they go or how can
they take part sure the las vegas
rotary.com and you just look for santa
claus there you can donate or if you
know of somebody who you think should
benefit
please reach out to that email address
or one of the partner agencies on your
website and the rotary club just does so
much in the community how special are
these events and to see everyone in the
community come together and support you
guys in everything that you do yes
rotary is a civic organization and we
are about to celebrate our centennial
next year in the valley so we've been
around for some time but we're not the
only club there's a bunch of clubs
around and we you know we care about the
youth and we want to help where we can
well thank you for all that you do and
we're going to help so many kids this
year and i can't believe 26th year we're
heading into
it's just gonna keep getting bigger and
better and i can't wait to see what you
guys do next so thank you so much
michael and for all the information of
how you can take part there's your
information on the screen december 2nd
for more information just go to las
vegasry.com
we'll be right back